this morning british prime minister
boris johnson a strong ally of mr trump
is wishing him and the first lady a
quote
speedy recovery johnson had his own
battle with the virus six months ago
and took weeks to recover charlie
dagetta looks at kovid's impact
on world leaders outside the u.s
three days after boris johnson was seen
cheering on hospital workers
they were fighting to save his life
later he said it was hard to believe
that in just a few days his health had
deteriorated to the extent
where contingency plans were being drawn
up to announce his death
if this virus were a physical assailant
an unexpected and invisible mugger
which i can tell you from personal
experience it is
like president trump johnson too had
downplayed the seriousness of the virus
i shook hands with everybody you'll be
pleased to know and i continue to shake
hands
they're not alone brazilian president
jair bolsonaro came down with it after
referring to kovit as
the little flu then there's iran's
deputy health minister breaking out in a
sweat
while assuring the country it was under
control
even now fellow colleagues reportedly
say the prime minister is nowhere near
the old boris that he's suffering from
long-term symptoms such as
breathlessness and fatigue
and while he has struggled with his
weight the prime minister was 55
when he tested positive with kovid 19
years younger than president trump
for cbs this morning charlie dagetta
london